dubai is often viewed as one of the
bougiest areas in the world from the
burj khalifa and the burj all arab to
the atlantis and the dozens of lavish
malls it seems like dubai is one of the
best places in the world to live combine
this with a no income tax and it's not
surprising why so many rich individuals
decide to retire in dubai with that
being said though dubai often hogs the
global spotlight when it comes to the
uae and the people often overlook the
emirate right next to it abu dhabi
while abu dhabi isn't talked about it
nearly as often they're just as well off
if not more well-off and one of their
biggest flexes is their extremely
wealthy sovereign wealth fund abu
dhabi's wealth fund currently manages
697 billion dollars
this isn't quite the biggest in the
world as there's three countries with
even larger funds however the thing to
note is that the countries with larger
funds have significantly larger
populations as well the most recent
population numbers from abu dhabi
indicate that there's 1.54 million
residents in the city if we divide 697
billion dollars by 1.54 million people
we get a whopping 452 452
597 dollars per person but it gets even
better than that
you see while all residents of the
emirates directly or indirectly benefit
from the sovereign wealth fund the fund
is primarily meant for abu dhabi
citizens and as we know most of the
people in the uae aren't actually
citizens it's estimated that only 11.48
of the uae's population are nationals of
the country while 88.52 percent are
expats
this number is likely skewed by dubai
but even if we assume that 20 of abu
dhabi's residents are nationals we only
get 308 000 people
and if we divide 697 billion dollars by
308 000 people we get a cool
2.262 million dollars per citizen
to put that in perspective if we divide
social security's 2.852 trillion dollars
in assets by the 291 million citizens in
the country we get um
thousand seven hundred and seventy four
dollars per citizen
but before you try to move to abu dhabi
unless you're from a neighboring country
you won't be able to wiggle yourself in
anytime soon
the uae has extremely strict citizenship
policies and you'll need to live in the
uae for at least 30 years to even apply
so while you and i probably can't
benefit from this it's insane to see how
well-off abu dhabi citizens really are
just a hundred years ago though abu
dhabi was a no-name country that was
filled with nomads who were just trying
to fight for daily survival so here's
how the average abu dhabi national went
from being nomads to being
multi-millionaires within just a few
generations
taking a look back the story of abu
dhabi only dates back to 1761.
before 1761 there's no records of human
civilization in the town specifically
which makes sense given that the area
was just a desert which is extremely
difficult to inhabit without the help of
modern technology nonetheless a few
tribesmen from the all buffalo clan
decided to set up a small town in abu
dhabi in 1761.
originally the area was called mill
which means salt in arabic one of the
driving factors of the early abu dhabi
economy was pro-diving the tribesmen
would trade these pearls with the
iranians and the indians this provided
them with enough capital to sustain a
small civilization but abu dhabi's
population never exceeded a few thousand
people in fact even at the start of 1900
abu dhabi only had a total of 6 000
residents despite the small population
abu dhabi would soon struggle to even
support these residents you see it
throughout the early 1900s japan's
pearling industry would take off which
led to abu dhabi losing most of their
customers
to make things worse the great
depression would hit in 1929 which wiped
out the few remaining customers abu
dhabi had
in desperation residents diverted their
focus onto camel herding and the
production of dates and vegetables but
things were quite rough most residents
lived in huts built from palm leaves
while wealthy residents lived in
mudbrick homes but soon enough the
country would get a glimpse of hope on
march 3rd 1938 saudi arabia would not
only discover oil but one of the largest
oil reserves in the world
abu dhabi's ruler at the time sheikh
shakbat would instantly authorize
foreign companies to come in and start
looking for oil in 1939 but this turned
out to be an extremely long process you
see world war ii would really pick up
steam in the first half of the 1940s
which put all exploration on hold
even after world war ii though the
search for oil was rather difficult due
to the large sand dunes and sandstorms
all across abu dhabi also the oil
companies were likely not that motivated
to find oil in abu dhabi after all abu
dhabi was a rather small area and they
had already found an ocean of oil in
saudi arabia so they had little need to
find oil in abu dhabi as well
nonetheless they kept looking and the
first sign of discovery would come in
1951
light traces of oil and gas would be
discovered at the merbin number one well
at a depth of ten thousand feet
engineers would enthusiastically
continue drilling deeper but at twelve
thousand five hundred feet they would
make an unpleasant discovery tower gas
sour gas is a natural gas that's
extremely poisonous and flammable
one petroleum engineer would
unfortunately be killed when sour gas
burst out from the pipes
for obvious reasons drilling at the site
was halted but the search for oil was
not
and eventually in 1958 abu dhabi would
finally discover oil at the amsha field
nearly 20 years after the search had
begun
while abu dhabi had struck oil oil money
didn't change the emirate all that much
you see it shake shake butt was
extremely cautious of spending the oil
money because he didn't know how long it
would last
it took 19 years to find a viable oil
field and if this field ran dry it could
take another 19 years or even more to
find another
so while sheik shakbat spent some of the
money on concrete buildings and paved
roads he saved the vast majority of it
but as years passed and abu dhabi was
able to negotiate better profit sharing
agreements much of the government and
the people felt that shakeshak but could
be less frugal these tensions would
eventually blow over in 1966 when sheik
shakbat was basically forced to retire
and replaced by his brother syed unlike
sheikh shakbat sheikh zayed was
extremely optimistic and felt that oil
money could revolutionize abu dhabi
forever but he decided to start simple
and establish the basic necessities of a
city he went ahead and started building
a road network that connected the center
of the city with the various villages
around the city he also built a sea wall
on the north side of the city which
protected the city from future damage
from the ocean he followed up these
constructions with electricity running
water and the central sewage system once
the necessities were covered he shifted
his focus onto building modern
government buildings hotels and housing
projects
around the same time britain would also
leave the persian gulf which allowed for
the uae to gain political independence
soon after abu dhabi would be made the
provisional capital of the uae which
made sheikh zayed the president of the
entire country within just 10 years abu
dhabi went from being a city of nomads
to gaining independence and rapidly
industrializing but sheikh zayed was
careful not to let this progress get to
his head sheikh zayed was well aware
that the oil money could stop at any
point and that eventually the world
would move towards more sustainable
forms of energy so he started investing
excess oil revenue as soon as possible
initially in 1967 he created the
financial investments board which was
responsible for investing the excess oil
revenue this was quite an ambitious move
for the time
you see back then and even now countries
mainly invest their money into gold and
bonds so to create an investing body
that would make investments outside
these categories was quite unique this
investing body didn't last long though
sheikh zayed soon realized that for such
a system to truly be effective it had to
be distanced from the government as much
as possible so in 1976 sheikh zayed
founded a new organization called the
abu dhabi investment authority or the
adia as you would guess he transferred
the responsibility of investing access
oil revenue over to them and this marks
the beginning of abu dhabi's sovereign
wealth fund
ever since the fund was founded they
have fully invested into basically
everything you can think of this
includes equities fixed income
treasuries real estate private equity
and hedge funds abu dhabi doesn't
release a full report of all of their
holdings like norway but they do release
a breakdown of the categories in which
they're invested taking a look at the
breakdown we can see that their biggest
investment is in developed equities
where they hold between 32 and 42
percent of their money they also hold a
decent amount in emerging market
equities and government bonds the
smallest category however is small cap
equities where they only invest one to
five percent of their money
as you can see the adis holdings are
pretty well diversified and they avoid
risky investments as much as possible
but things don't always go their way
over the decades they've made a handful
of painful mistakes that have cost them
hundreds of millions and sometimes even
billions one of these mistakes was
getting involved in the bank of credit
and commerce international or the bcci
in the 1980s the bcci was the seventh
largest private bank in the world with
over 20 billion dollars in assets so it
likely seemed like a pretty safe place
to invest some money but the bcci would
eventually be linked with a massive
money laundering scheme and loads of
other financial crimes which led to the
bank closing in 1991 and the adia losing
hundreds of millions similarly another
major mistake that adia made was
investing heavily in 2007 and 8. the
adia was literally buying the top of the
housing bubble and one of their biggest
investments was 7.5 billion dollars into
citigroup once the housing bubble popped
out citigroup stock crashed 90 percent
and it never recovered the adia suffered
several similar losses during this time
period but despite the downfall the adia
continued to consistently invest and
it's worked out pretty well for them
overall
the last time the adia revealed annual
returns was in 2010 and at the time they
boasted an average annual return of 8.1
percent over the past 30 years so they
basically just match market returns but
it should be noted that the adia is
likely far more diversified than the s p
500
at the end of the day having hundreds of
billions in the bank is great and all
but the goal is to eventually cash in at
a sustainable pace
abu dhabi has avoided cashing in as much
as possible because they have much
bigger ambitions for this fund they
don't want the fund to just give their
citizens a solid retirement but
eventually make up for oil revenue as
the world transitions to sustainable
energy this is why one of the top goals
of the fund is to move all of their
assets to sustainable investments
we don't know exactly how much the adia
has in sustainable investment but some
sources suggest that the figure is
around two-thirds so abu dhabi still has
some work to do but it looks like
they're headed in the right direction
with that being said though it doesn't
look like withdrawals will become a
thing anytime soon
it seems like abu dhabi really wants to
get the fun to trillions of dollars
first just like norway so in the
meantime abu dhabi citizens are only
multi-millionaires on paper but hey it's
still way better than social security do
you guys think more countries should
embrace a sovereign wealth fund comment
that down below
also drop a like if you wish you had a
part of abu dhabi's pie and of course
consider checking out our international
channels to watch our videos in other
languages and consider subscribing see
more questions logically answered but
until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys on the next one